round four if the sink filled cup here  in st. Louis four players came into the  day tied for first place and looking to  break away from the pack five-time world  champion Viswanathan Anand could only  neutralize ding Liren slight opening  advantage while Levon Aronian who was  feeling under the weather got nothing  out of his opening against fabiano  caruana and a game that ended peacefully  grandchester co-leader wesley so  immediately got into trouble against an  ish eerie but alert defense and  emphasized play by the tournament's  youngest player allowed the american to  save the game facility open log  sacrifices queen to get a wonderful  position against the chiro nakamura but  the bulgarian star failed to land the  blow and had to fight to make the draw  the important midpoint of the tournament  has arrived with the same leaderboard  looking to shake things up the story of  who will try to grab the torch and  finally take the lead starts right now